[Music]
saturday this franchise is unlike
anything I've ever seen you have fans
around the world the way that we have
the motivation and inspiration is beyond
your wildest imagination and fans who
are incredibly loyal but they're also
very very vocal you know you listen to
the audience we feel the weight of that
and because of that we move forward what
we wanted to do was capitalize off of
what the sizes represented for the last
two decades and attempt to challenge it
the hell of a job roller when we get
back to the face beers on me only way
we're really going to be able to
continue this story was to expose the
darker more dangerous side to dr. Adam
and that's what we have to do
it's too late for me get out of here
Dominic Toretto just turned on us this
is a completely different story than you
ever experienced in the fast franchise
Dom it's always about family and with
this storyline he's gone up against the
team and he's going up against her
family what better way to turn this
entire franchise on his head and to do
something like that did you ever think
you'd betray your family the way you did
today then he throw in the element of
Charlie's alone I love that Charlize in
this movie she really set the tone she's
definitely the fiercest villain the
franchise has ever seen the whole new
start to the franchise and that's what
we continue to do is reinvent ourselves
that's all right house click the wheel
what
pretty crazy
all right you get style points
throughout feita superior is going to
Bocas was mine blow people's minds
[Music]
fire
you
you